texas governor greg abbott taking the
border crisis into his own hands
now directing state law enforcement to
start arresting illegal immigrants for
trespassing
national border council president
brandon judd joins us now
to react brandon hey brandon good
morning
hi rachel how are you so tell us what
this will do i mean you're now the state
of
texas is going to arrest people do you
think this will solve the problem is it
enough
uh it's not going to solve the problem
but you have to there's two things you
have to look at you have to be ecstatic
that a governor is stepping up
and doing the job that the federal
government isn't doing he's stepping up
and he's going to deliver
a consequence he's going to take a a
page out of the trump playbook
and he's going to deliver a consequence
for those people that are crossing
border illegally but you have to be
extremely upset
that this governor is doing the job of
the federal government
the biden administration refuses to
protect the american public
by giving the resources to the border
patrol that is necessary
for us to secure the border you know as
we go out we and we put the uniform on
as we we patrol the border
if we don't have an administration that
is backing us up
that is giving us those resources then
you're going to see this crisis continue
to
to get bigger but governor governor
abbott stepping up it's going to help
texas
but it's likely to push the illegal
immigration to states like new mexico
arizona and california
it's like a balloon hey really quickly
brandon out of curiosity so trespassing
seems like an obvious charge i'm sure
it's one that can stick
can border patrol enforce that does that
have to be through state authorities
these special task force because that's
a state crime a federal law enforcement
agency
wouldn't be making those arrests right
or passing them
it's going gonna have to be uh by the
state the the federal government can't
enforce uh state laws
so the the state's gonna have to step in
and they're gonna do it and and that's
exactly what governor abbott is
in fact doing right are there is there a
capacity
i mean do they have the capacity to do
this so when we see all these images on
the border of border patrol agents
bringing dealing with migrants uh
they're not going to be charged with
trespassing there it's the ones that get
through
yeah no it's going to have to be those
individuals that are taken into custody
by the state so
the people that are taken into custody
by the border patrol they're not going
to be turned around and charged by the
state
so when texas dps or when a county
sheriff
takes somebody that crosses the border
illegally into custody then they can
charge those individuals with uh
criminal trespassing and so yeah
right it is a very good step in the
right direction brandon let me ask you
something else the
uh biden administration said they want
to do an infrastructure um
you know bill this huge trillion dollar
bill that they want to do however
they've stopped construction it's one of
the first things that
joe biden did when he got into obviously
stop construction of an infrastructure
project on the wall um on the southern
border
however they're still paying two billion
dollars i guess to pay
to to fulfill the contract and tell
people and tell those companies not
so they're paying for the wall that's
yeah they're paying people not to work
is that is that what's happening
yeah yeah it's crazy and to avoid
litigation the biden administration is
in fact paying these uh contracting
companies
the money that they were scheduled to
make but they're just not doing any work
for it
so yeah they're taking american
taxpayers money
and they're just not getting anything
out of it more paying people not to work
that's exactly
and and by the way like we don't have a
problem at the border that we don't need
a wall like we're seeing
a hundred and eighty thousand people
come every month
that you know unbelievable no brandon
outrageous story
thank you for uh breaking these down for
us this morning thanks brandon thank you
brandon thank you